scp-004 - J object class thermal special
containment procedures the entity is
currently housed in the side 0-1 north
wing accountants payable office from
Monday to Friday between the hours of
zero 800 to 1700 hours local with one
hour from 1200 to 1300 hours locally
spent in the North cafeteria or
traversing from there back to his desk
the entity may occasionally need to use
the restroom take breaks by walking the
north wing corridor or receive water
from the water fountain in the long term
the entity can be contained by pioneer
or performance reviews indicating that
we are pleased by think the entity is
capable of more and annual raises
equivalent to the pay rate of inflation
plus four percentage points the entity
may also be enticed to remain in
containment by pointing out the low cost
of living easy commute and quality
public parks description scp-004 - J
Stanley Nichols a certified public
accountant University of Michigan 1978
and former chief financial officer fall
currently employed by the foundation
scp-004 - J is roughly 180 centimeters
tall and weighs roughly 75 kilograms
Caucasian with finning brown hair and
brown eyes the entity has been in
foundation containment since July 1991
ostensibly in reply to a job posting the
anomalous properties of the entity
manifested after the jumpers awarded
during mandatory psych and low-level
amnestic administration the staffer
assigned to the task flatly refused to
administer amnestics to the entity
claiming the scp-004 - j was a real
visionary and that it would be a waste
of drugs and a needless capex hit after
a brief convention by hiring department
the compulsion and Cognito hazard unit
and site zero for subject matter expert
on hazardous humanoids the agreement was
made to contain scp-004 - j under the
price of hiring them for the desired
position in accounts payable
scp-004 - j appears to be a very capable
accountant and has made commendable
efforts
in both lowering our annual capital
expenditure budget while streamlining
our vendor and purchase process for
operating expenditures furthermore their
holistic approach of purchasing and
leveraging the growing
internationalization of the supply chain
has caused a sea change in our view of
synergistic possibilities to creating a
budget conscious deliverable leading to
a paradigm shift of crowd-sourced it
appears the entity was in my vicinity of
briefly summarize scp-004 - jay has a
distinct kognito hazard-filled that will
interfere with four processes overriding
fault patterns with new ones that
encourage growing a business for a set
of jargon commonly used by c-level
executives while also impairing the
ability to think critically CT scans of
foundation employees in the field of
scp-004 - Jay show a lowered neuron
excitement state in the occipital cortex
and hippocampus both linked to critical
thinking logic and reasoning scp-004 -
jay was classed as euclid in August of
1991 scp-004 - jay was recast as thermal
in october of 1992 following a
near-total containment breach in August
of 1992 caused by structural damage
suffered during Hurricane Andrew at
sites during which scp-004 - Jay was
exposed to scp-106 which is classed kita
and invariably hostile to human life
rather than panic or hide scp-004 - Jay
began discussing the importance of
residual income and annuities while
structuring a quarterly budget scp-106
appeared a rapt with attention
materialized a business card and agreed
to join scp-004 - Jay for a Lunch and
Learn at his soon as convenience
further testing has shown that the
kognito has its surrounding scp-004 - j
affects not only humanoids but every
sentient life-form that has been exposed
in furtherance of a hypothesis posted by
doctors McKinley and white scp-004 - J
or stationed outside the containment
cell of scp-682 at a safe distance but
close enough to have notorious creature
in its kognito hazardous fields audio
follows audio log 0 0 4 - J - II does 6
8 2 - 0 0 1 a CP 682 could you repeat
that
bottom line I'm sorry
in this economy sucker bet scp-682 do
your own property here no choice SS like
[ __ ] product know from researcher at
this point free common white mice are
introduced into scp-682 s containment
cell scp-682 normally devours prey on
site conference for life since
redundancies
we must smart size to better push the
envelop you know for competences scp-682
then dismembers and he's two of the free
mice i hope they find their settlements
suitable
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre Bessette
thank you very much Hungary your pledge
is very much appreciated if you would
like to know how you can get a
personalized thank e at the end of each
of my videos as well as some other
really cool stuff as well go to
patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
you
[Music]